did FTX have sufficient Risk Management
Systems
and controls to appropriately monitor
any leverage the business took on and
the interconnections it had with
businesses lack again Alameda
there were virtually no internal
controls and no separateness whatsoever
so what is what is the um the the big
picture
um balance loss as a result of this
bankruptcy how much how much has FTX
lost as a result of this we don't have
exact numbers but we know several
billion dollars you know in excess of
seven billion can you provide some
indication of whether customer funds
from ftx.com were in fact transferred to
Alameda research
it was definitely assets of of customers
in the.com Silo were transferred to
elevated no question about it uh uh we
have not seen this at this stage from
the U.S Silo but of course you know we
do have one concern and that's the
concern we're chasing down which is
whether or not there's commingling
between the.com Silo and the U.S Silo
exchanges and and the reason for that is
we know that there was sort of common
control and access
uh of authorized users at this most
Senior Management level amongst all of
the assets so it's something we have to
we have to focus on we haven't seen
evidence right now of that uh but
certainly that's something we need to
investigate and Trace are you yet in a
position to be able to describe
summarize the assets that Alameda had
we do have you know an inventory of uh
of the Investments we made uh that's
pretty clear we've got those in the
hands of uh our investment bankers at
perella and we're trying to understand
those Investments uh ultimately we'll
Market those Investments you'll see this
week that some of those Investments uh
will be uh will be put up for sale uh
the crypto assets a little bit different
what's on the exchanges we can see
there's exchanges about two dozen
exchanges across the world where we know
we have crypto assets they're in our
name we're securing those and removing
those in the cold storage
uh we have you know other uh positions
and cold wallets and hot walls we've got
visibility to that
the question really is are there wallets
that we don't know about
certainly that is the potential because
the way this company was organized there
may be wallets that don't have our names
we don't know where they are and that's
going to be you know a difficult task
ahead of us but what we can see what we
have visibility to we're grabbing
control over what are some of the
biggest questions you still have for Mr
bankman freed and his associates now
that you've been through this for some
period
look I I think the questions we have are
not necessarily Mr a question for Mr
free the questions we have are you know
where where are the assets how we locate
those assets
uh it's a mining exercise at this point
uh and uh
look I you know at the end of the day
we're not going to be able to recover
all the losses here right uh money was
spent it will never get back there will
be losses on the international side
we're hopeful on the U.S side
um he'll answer to others related to
what happened here our job is just to
you know find the assets and try to get
customers their money back as quickly as
possible